garrett and frederick brown 48 years old
twin brothers from hamburg with a
passion for playing here it is a few
minutes older than frederick and with
his technical skills he puts his
brothers way out ideas into practice
Java has invited some biz info we're
both a little crazy we love to play
we're alike in that respect but in other
things although not many we're different
I think I'm a bit more optimistic than
Garrett's gathered for design has leaked
out but that's because I take care of
the technical things he comes up with
sensational ideas I have to admit but
I'm the one who has to make them happen
365 days a year 10 hours a day it's my
job to find out what can go wrong as a
man I off guard as hot as a pizza zoom
the twins in their miniature of
Wonderland in Hamburg their microcosm is
steadily expanding this autumn they'll
be opening their latest feature Italy
with models of architectural
masterpieces from Rome with a total
tract length of 15.4 km/h railway made
the guinness book of world records again
last year Fredrik Brown takes care of
marketing and personnel Garrett has the
technical know-how
Jesus spilling space that twin gene is
always coming together again and wanting
to do something together but I deserve
on all kinds of its ed I said there's
another thing he's really a technical
genius doesn't end up I always say he
got it from me at birth you turn ons are
you so when computers came along in our
youth Gary did everything for me I'm
Buddha I didn't even know how to
configure the things seem otherwise
confused he had to do double the work
and that's how he got so good done with
your shift universe on he said this
things would go on they also encourage
there are 300 or so employees to have
fun and come up with new ideas it's
interesting that the twins are so good
at motivating others because as children
they were entirely focused on each other
bat'leth keen on vagueness as kids we
had our own language only he couldn't
understand me that's it buddy our mother
told us that we were late in speaking
because we had our own way of
communicating nice piano you ever you
got woken up we made noises that only we
understood loss get internet outswinger
i had twins myself now they're 20 months
old and starting to talk but often
they're facing each other and babbling
and one starts laughing like crazy it's
an interaction only they understanding
the Browns mother wanted them to learn
to be individuals but she soon had to
realize the twins can't easily be parted
prevents pangit think we were in
separate classes but as soon as school
was over we were back together again we
did everything together we're not even
in school we occasionally switched
classes so it didn't work any Pleasance
of excellent as I said Nick from Sonia
in their work on the miniatur wunderland
project the twins mutual understanding
was a great advantage
any cooler when I hear he's in a certain
situation I know precisely how he feels
because we're the same and when he
reacts to me I know exactly why there's
no other person they have that with so
clearly that's my TV camera and I
mentioned your diaper who are you I
think what am I thinking that I talk too
much both Garrett and Frederick are
married and each of them has three
children today Frederick's wife Johanna
has joined it for lunch in the canteen
of the Miniato of Underland so what's it
like being married to a twin month on to
the jpn permadeath you should definitely
get along with the other sibling mine
what that helps and it was no problem in
our case oh and and you have to be
understanding of the fact that you're
not always in first place but sometimes
in second place or even then third but
you'll always have a sympathetic
listener my pendant amount often as well
how well did the twins know each other
really we do a little test garrard
orders two dishes for his brother did he
get them right
oh that's good I thought so forty
percent I'd eat this sixty percent ID
badges they're my two favorite foods
money Bailey please Victor spaghetti
bolognese and schnitzel Garrett passed
the test the brown twins from Hamburg
two men who turned their childhood
passion for model trains into an
attraction for millions of visitors
you